Das ist auch bei den Münchnern so gewesen. Die haben mit den Franken zusammen gestanden. Entschuldigung. Dann gab es das Heckzugtum. Ich nehme an, das war Paraborn, da die Ecke. Würde ich jetzt einfach vermuten, ohne das zu wissen. Meinst du?
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Weiß das irgendjemand? Gut, falls jemand weiß. Dann gab es noch, was ich sehr lustig fand, die Kinky Geeks. Habt ihr die Kinky Geeks angeguckt?
Ich habe sie nicht angeguckt, aber ich habe ihre Präsenz zur Kenntnis genommen.
Ich habe es mir angeschaut.
Auch da gibt es ein... Sie haben zumindest ein Maßgeblich... Sie haben auf jeden Fall maßgeblich in einem wichtigen, lehrreichen Film des Zards eine Rolle gespielt. Und auch...
Ich habe sie nicht gesehen.
Also auf jeden Fall gucken. Auf jeden Fall.
Wir hatten ja irgendwie das Problem, dass es, also es war ja auf dem Acker, das heißt irgendwie ist potenziell auch Unwettergefahr und irgendwie Zelte fliegen durch die Gegend. Und das Zert hat sich irgendwie den Spaß gemacht und hat gesagt, wir haben hier das Problem mit losen Zelten, dann drehen wir doch mal einen Lehrfilm aller Sendungen mit der Maus und erklären, wie man irgendwie sein Zelt absichert. Also der ist wirklich großartig, super eingesprochen, super, die Leute, die da mitgespielt haben, das passt einfach perfekt. Also muss man sich auf jeden Fall angucken. Nee, gibt's auch auf Media, denke ich.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob's den auf Media gibt. Es gibt den auf jeden Fall.
Dann gibt's den auf jeden Fall bald auf Media.
Genau, das ist Bernd.
Es gibt den bestimmt schon in den Show Notes.
Genau, in die Show Notes. Die Show Notes haben das gekovvert. Wunderbar. Genau. Und das Ganze ist, glaube ich, auch mit zurückzuführen darauf, dass wir die Besonderheit hatten, dass der Ralf Kaspers einen Vortrag gehalten hat. Das ist jener welcher, der auch unter anderem bei der Sendung mit der Maus immer wieder Beiträge abliefert. Genau, und er hat halt quasi einfach erzählt, wie man Dinge knackig rüberbringt und da hat sich das Zert nicht lange bitten lassen.
Also ist es erst nach dem Vortrag entstanden, oder was? Soweit ich weiß, ja. Das sind eben so die ganzen Sachen, die man immer erst ein, zwei Wochen nach der Veranstaltung mitkriegt, was da alles so an lustigen Sachen passiert ist. Auch so diese ganzen coolen, kleinen Snorts zwischendurch, die auch in der Abschlussveranstaltung nochmal zur Sprache kamen.
Erzählt mal, wie war denn das? Da gab es irgendwie einen schönen Snort mit einer unter Wasser stehenden Stromleitung?
Vielleicht sollten wir erstmal auf diesen Vorfall mit der Wettersituation eingehen.
Das macht das halt etwas klarer.
Also ist ja Sommer und wie wir alle wissen, es kann schönes Wetter sein und wenn es dann mal schlecht wird, dann wird es auch schnell mal sehr schlecht. Und so war es dann auch. Es zog also eine Gewitterfront heran, die uns dann auch voll erwischt hat. Also es hat wohl mindestens einen Blitzeinschlag irgendwo auf den Camp gegeben. Es ist jetzt keiner zu Schaden gekommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwelche Erkenntnisse darüber gibt. Der nächste Blitzeinschlag war so wie 150 Meter weg und hat auch einen Baum richtig getroffen und zermatscht. Im Norden oder im Süden? Als es schon vorbei war? Ich weiß, dass das Ding über uns rüberzog. Aber es gab einen richtig lauten. Ich meinte, es war richtig laut. Da war der Unterschied zwischen den beiden. Ich glaube, es war im Norden. Ja, da gab es dann auch tatsächlich einen Evakuierungsplan, der aktiviert wurde. Was dazu führte, dass viele Leute aufgefordert wurden, ihre Zelte zu verlassen und sich in die Schutzräume zu begeben. Das waren natürlich vor allem Autos. Oder das Getränkelager. Das Getränkelager.
Oder ein Sprinter.
Es gab auch, glaube ich, ein Gebäude von dem C-Geleitpark, das da in Fragen kam, etc. Das ist an sich gut verlaufen, muss man sagen. Also nicht, dass jetzt alle evakuiert wurden. Und sicherlich standen auch nicht alle in wirklich blitzgesicherten Zelten. Aber hat immerhin geklappt. Und danach hat es nochmal so eine halbe Stunde richtig ordentlich geregnet. Also so richtig doll geklappt, das nicht. Also in der Theorie war das irgendwie sicherlich gut durchdacht gewesen. Aber in der Praxis, also es war auf jeden Fall, das hätte deutlich besser laufen können.
Mit anderen Worten, wir brauchen auf anderen Camps mehr Schlechtwetter-Situationen, um das mal perfekt zu trainieren.
Ja, so wie das halt immer ist.
Beim ersten Mal gehen halt irgendwie noch Sachen schief und man lernt auch draus.
Aber ich meine, von der Theorie war es auf jeden Fall richtig, das zu machen. Also weil so ein Zeltplatz mit Gewitter drüber, das ist einfach mal echt gefährlich, mit Bäumen, die dann auf Zelte fallen können oder Zelte, die irgendwo einschlagen in der Nähe.
Aber es gab halt auch, es gab Kommunikation. Also ich kann mich jetzt nicht wirklich beklagen. Es hätte sicherlich an einigen Stellen besser laufen können. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, wir waren immer informiert. Was Sache war, stand halt keiner im strömenden Regen.
Ja doch, genau das war das Problem. Die Leute standen im strömenden Regen, weil halt diese Evakuierung einfach zu spät losgetreten wurde. Das heißt irgendwie, dann sind die, die das Zelt halt rumgelaufen hat, gesagt, wieso jetzt verlasst mal bitte irgendwie das Zelt, was halt total Sinn macht. Aber wenn es halt irgendwie vor zwei Minuten angefangen hat, im Ström zu regnen, ist es schwierig, die Leute zu überzeugen, jetzt nochmal das Zelt zu verlassen. Das heißt, man hätte es einfach mal eine Viertelstunde früher machen können, dann wäre es auf jeden Fall irgendwie deutlich in geordneteren Bahnen abgelaufen.
Auf der anderen Seite, gerade so ein Gewitter, es sind ja mehrere Gewitter auch einfach schlicht in der Gaffnung an uns vorbeigezogen.
Zwei Tage vorher gab es doch auch schon mal ein Gewitter, wo es dann ein Lärz auch richtig geballert hat. Und da war sehr lustig, da fuhr die Lebensrettungsgesellschaft ganz entspannt über den Platz und sagte immer durch, Moin, Moin, wir erwarten in den nächsten Stunden ein wenig Wind und etwas Regen. Wo wir dann so dastehen und sagen, okay, ein wenig Wind, Moin, Moin, okay, was machen wir jetzt?
Nüscht. Das war aber nicht hier auf dem Camp, oder?
Es war auf dem Camp, aber es war zwei Tage vorher.
Das war die erste Unwetterwärme. Also da war es tatsächlich auch so, dass ein Gewitterfront irgendwie angerückt ist, die sich aber glücklicherweise genauso um Mildenberg rumgetreten hat, die Hälfte am Norden, die Hälfte im Süden vorbeigegangen. Und es war abzusehen, dass das passiert, aber wir dachten uns, naja, lassen wir es mal trotzdem durchlaufen, dann können die Leute schon mal irgendwie ihre Zelte sichern, weil es kommt auf jeden Fall in den nächsten Tagen noch ein großes Wunder her. Daher war das gar nicht so verkehrt, das so laufen zu lassen. Es hat auf jeden Fall dann geregnet, dann war es halt auch nass, was jetzt auf dem Gelände auch nicht so das große Problem war, weil wir natürlich den Vorteil hatten. Ziegeleihpark heißt, das Ganze ist ein Industriegelände. Da sind schon immer große Geräte, Bagger etc. unterwegs gewesen. Das heißt, dieser ganze Rasen, den wir genutzt haben, ist halt, soweit ich weiß, durchgehend unterschottert. Sprich, da weicht jetzt nicht gleich alles auf. Es gab natürlich die eine oder andere Pfütze, aber halt jetzt nichts Dramatisches, dass sich da riesige Löcher auftun oder man in großen Wasserschlammen wandelt.
Es war keine Schlammschlacht in keiner Weise.
Es war keine Schlammschlacht, überhaupt nicht, aber es hat schon ganz ordentlich geregnet und danach hatten die Nerds halt ihren Spaß und dann ist halt diese coole Installation, wo dann irgendwie so eine dieser Pfützen dazu genutzt wurden, so ganz dekorativ, da so eine stinknormale Dreifachstecker-Verteiler-Wohnzimmer-Dose im Wasser zu versenken, die so sehr, naja, wasserüberdeckt einfach total bedrohlich aussah.
Das dampfte da, glaube ich.
Ja, es wäre halt keinem aufgefallen, wenn sie nicht noch so klug gewesen, noch so einen Würfel Trockenheiss dazu zu schmeißen. Womit das dann halt auch noch so nebelschwaden.
Mit anderen Worten, was immer daran angeschlossen war, war in Wirklichkeit auf Batterie.
Da war halt gar nichts dran angeschlossen. Das war halt einfach so ne temporäre... Es war ein Baustrahler angeschlossen, der aber batteriebetrieben war. Sie haben auch echt ne gute Performance dazu gemacht. Also mit rumlaufen und so. Fasst ihr nicht an und immer so runter und... Also es war schon ganz lustig. Also man hätte merken können, das ist irgendwie nicht... Super Nerd-Humor. Sind auf jeden Fall einige Leute an die Decke gegangen. Da seid ihr wahnsinnig verängsheit.
Das klingt doch erstmal sehr, sehr flottig.
Ja, hat also eigentlich alles funktioniert. Und es war auch mal ganz interessant zu sehen, es gab ja dann auch die Entscheidung wegen des Gewitters, den Strom komplett abzuschalten. Also nicht nur die Generatoren auszuschalten, sondern die Generatoren mussten ausgeschaltet werden, weil man halt die Kabel trennen wollte. Weil, keine Ahnung, das kann ich nicht so richtig bewerten. Schon halt sein kann, so ein Generator ist, sagen wir mal, durchaus so ein Blitzmagnet. Und wäre es da halt reingeschossen, hätte es sich dann eben auch durch das ausgelegte Stromnetz leichter verteilen können, wo natürlich dann viele Geräte dranhängen und Zelte und so weiter. Das wollte man vermeiden. Und war interessant zu sehen, dass man einfach dieses ganze Camp mal eine Viertelstunde runterfahren kann und wieder hochfahren kann. Und danach war es auch alles wieder bunt und Internet gab und deckt funktionierte. Also auch ein ganz ordentlicher Test.
Gut, dann wollen wir uns jetzt noch gleich die Nerd News anhören. Und dann geht es gleich noch weiter hier im Chaos Radio.
Die Nerd News Mit Web.de und GMX wollen zwei deutsche E-Mail-Anbieter, die zum Internetkonzern United Internet gehören, auf den Internetstandard Dane setzen. Mittels Dane können beliebige Provider untereinander die E-Mails ihrer Kunden verschlüsselt austauschen. Damit kehrt United Internet der proprietären Insellösung E-Mail Made in Germany den Rücken, mit der deutsche Anbieter ohne Dane untereinander E-Mails verschlüsselt austauschen wollten. Auch die Regierungs-Server auf Bund.de verwenden bereits Dane. Auch wenn durch Dane noch keine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung gewährleistet wird, ist Dane eine Verbesserung gegenüber der sonst gewöhnlich unverschlüsselten E-Mail-Übertragung zwischen zwei Anbietern. Sicherheitsforscher haben aus einem internetfähigen Kühlschrank von Samsung das Google Login des Besitzers ausgelesen. Dabei machten sie sich zunutze, dass die Software die SSL-Zertifikate nicht prüft, die der Webserver zur Erstellung einer sicheren Verbindung vorweist. So ist der Kühlschrank durch eine Man-in-the-Middle-Attacke angreifbar. Da zum Funktionsumfang des Smart Fridges eine Google-Kalender-Anzeige gehört, kann ein Angreifer so beispielsweise die Google-Zugangsdaten auslesen, um an das Gmail-Contr des Kühlschrankbesitzers zu kommen. Samsung will nun nachbessern. Die Bundesregierung drängt auf eine Einführung der Vectoring-Technologie, um VDSL-Zugänge zu beschleunigen. Beim Vectoring werden mehrere Kupferadern gebündelt, um eine schnellere Datenübertragung mit bis zu 100 Megabit pro Sekunde zu ermöglichen. Ohne Vectoring liegt das Limit bei 50 Megabit pro Sekunde. Aus technischen Gründen benötigt beim Vectoring ein anbieter-exklusiven Zugriff auf einen Hauptverteiler, um in dessen Nahbereich Vectoring anbieten zu können. Dieses Privileg soll nach einem Bericht des Handelsplottes vollständig an die Telekom gehen. Das Bundeskanzleramt und die Ministerien für Wirtschaft und Verkehr drängen die Bundesnetzagentur dem Bericht zufolge zu einem Vertrag mit der Telekom. Darin soll diese sich im Gegenzug verpflichten, 80 Prozent der Haushalte mit Vectoring zu versorgen. Damit würden andere Telekommunikationsunternehmen Zugang zu den 8.000 Hauptverteilern der Telekom verlieren. Die Wettbewerber haben Klage angekündigt.
T-T-
Willkommen zurück zum Chaos Radio 215, wo wir uns heute über das Chaos Communication Congress Camp unterhalten wollen. Und zu uns auf die Couch ist der Sef gekommen. Hallo. Hallo. Und du hattest eine ganz besondere Rolle, nämlich du hast das BR Village mit organisiert. Das ist das Village vom Chaos Computer Club Berlin und Freunde, kann man das so sagen?
Genau, vom Chaos Computer Club und anderen Berliner Hacker-Spaces, wie den Lichtpiraten, Afra, RFA, C-Base. C-Base hatte noch ihr eigenes Village.
Das war ein Village Cluster, haben wir das gerade definiert.
Genau, der Village Cluster. Wie seid ihr zu diesem Village gekommen? Was habt ihr da für ein Konzept verfolgt? Kann man das überhaupt so fragen? Oder war das einfach so, lasst mal machen, super Sache?
Es war eigentlich nicht mehr das.
Ja, lass mal machen, geil, wir machen.
Camp. Okay, und wie sah das dann praktisch aus? Was habt ihr da auf die Wiese gestellt?
Also wir haben als erstes mal die Tippis, den Dom und die Infrastruktur auf den Platz gestellt. Und der Rest waren die verschiedenen Tippis.
Wir hatten ein Tippi.
Es gab ein Doppeltippi.
Ich glaube, da stellt sich jemand etwas unter den Scheffel gerade, weil diese Tippis waren fantastisch. Also darunter muss man auch mal sagen, das war so der Ort, wo man zum einen net chillen konnte. Da war die Bar, die Ajan unter einem nett bespielt hat. Und von dort aus hatte man auch einen herrlichen Blick auf die Bühne. Eine Bühne, da gab es auch noch eine lustige Geschichte, die war irgendwie nicht so die richtige Bühne.
Das Zelt über der Bühne war nicht das erste Zelt, das über dieser Bühne stand.
Ja, wir haben ein bisschen rumprobiert. Wir hatten erst das eine Tab, dann hatten wir das nächste Tab. Wir haben das alles ein bisschen mehrfach ausprobiert und haben uns dann am Ende für die Variante entschieden, die dann da stand.
Okay, aber es hat ja doch ganz ordentlich funktioniert. Tim kann da sicherlich irgendwie ein Lied von singen. Der hat nämlich da ein paar Mal auf der Bühne Sachen gemacht, nämlich ein paar seiner Podcasts. Zwischen Tippy und Bühne hat auch ganz gut Publikum gepasst. Auch das haben wir, glaube ich, mehrfach sehen können. Und als ganz besonderen Gast hatten wir dann ja auch noch eine Band, nämlich...
The Incredible Herringgedeck.
Genau.
Ja, ein super Combo. Wenn ihr ihn nicht kennt, schnell mal bei Google eingeben. Sehr lustig, sehr unterhaltsam, sehr passend. Ich fand das extrem passend. Also das war einfach so vom Mindset her genau das Richtige, finde ich. Das hat einfach super gepasst. Piepshow hatten wir auch noch. Ja, möchtest du das gleich ausrühren?
Das würde ich jetzt aber auch gerne von dir hören.
Von mir jetzt?
Ja, wenn du das ansprichst. Mir ist das jetzt auch tatsächlich völlig...
Es gibt was, was du verpasst hast auf dem Web.
Ausgrinde die Piepshow.
Wir sollten unbedingt sagen, dass die Piepshow da war. Und die Piepshow war da. Wahnsinn.
Die Piepshow ist einfach so ein kleiner roter Minitrack, der da noch aufgelaufen ist und nochmal so seinen eigenen kleinen Mini-Dancefloor temporär an einem Abend eröffnet hat und lustige Späße mit den Teilnehmern durchgeführt hat.
Ja, und Interaktion mit den Teilnehmern. Die Teilnehmer konnten bestimmen, durch Drücken von Knöpfen, was passieren soll.
Was passieren soll? Ist das einigermaßen safer work, wenn ich jetzt frage, was da passieren konnte?
Alkohol gab es dann, letztendlich.
Ausschließlich? Wir hatten auch die endlosen Leute, oder?
Es gab da auch soziale Interaktionen, die man aufrufen konnte, aber da möchte ich jetzt auch nicht so im Detail drauf eingehen.
Bleiben wir dabei. Es gab eine Piepshow.
Es war auf jeden Fall gut besucht und mit großartiger Stimmung und war wieder so ein kleiner Fnord auf dieser Veranstaltung, der so ganz unangekündigt auf einmal aufpoppte und dann irgendwann wieder verschwand.
Fnords sind überhaupt immer sehr beliebt. Also das funktioniert. Ich kenne das tatsächlich hauptsächlich irgendwie vom Kongress, aber auf dem Camp hat das irgendwie nochmal seine besondere Würze. Das ist irgendwie nochmal deutlich unerwarteter.
Ja, genauso wie dieser Party Train. Also ich meine, wir haben das ja schon ein paarmal erzählt, dass es halt eine Zuginfrastruktur gibt, die ja auf diesem Ziegelei-Park ohnehin immer in Betrieb ist. Damit fahren dann halt die Museumsbesucher über dieses Gelände und auch teilweise über dieses Gelände hinaus und lassen sich dann eben im Vorbeifahren das ein oder andere Feature dieses Ziegelei-Parks erläutern. Das fand ja dann auch skurrilerweise parallel auf dem Camp auch statt, dass da halt so Auswärtige über diesen Acker gefahren wurde und dann war halt einfach mal die Attraktion ausgetauscht.
Auch während des Aufbaus schon.
Auch während des Aufbaus.
Jeden Tag mehrfach.
Hier und schauen sie mal links und die Zelte und so. Und ja, außerdem kann man halt auch einen richtigen Rundkurs befahren auf dem Kerngelände des Camps und dann gab es halt so ein Party-Train. Wer hat das überhaupt angeleiert irgendwie?
Das hat man gemacht.
Das hat man gemacht und jetzt noch ein paar andere Vögel haben dann halt einfach diesen Zug dekoriert und er hatte dann seine eigene Cocktail-Bar, einen Wagen war halt ein Bälle-Bad.
Wo obskurerweise die Bälle öfters mal sortiert vorbeifuhren.
Jeden Morgen waren die sortiert. Jeden Morgen waren die farblich sortiert. Herr Munzberg, frag nicht, wer das war. Das Beste ist, dass am ersten Tag, da hast du mir relativ verzweifelt, neben mir stand und meinte, da waren überall Kinder und die Eltern waren nicht zu finden. Und am nächsten Tag war Volker richtig ein Schild dran, nur für große Kinder ab 18 Jahre. Und wir sind wirklich dann so, los, komm, wir haben einen Zug. Und dann stand da so ein Mädchen neben mir, darf mir heute nur große Kinder rein. Ich darf da jetzt nicht rein, hier gehts rein. Das fanden die richtig scheiße.
Nur für die Großen und so, voll gemein.
Aber die Nerds hatten ja eh traditionell Anspruch auf ein Bällebad.
Ja, aber das war schon ein bisschen eine fiese Aktion. Über die Argumentation konnte ich nachvollziehen, dass sie organisatorisch in dem Moment sich nicht ausreichend aufgestellt sahen, dafür die Sicherheit der Kinder zu sorgen. Zumal es wohl auch vorgekommen ist, dass Kinder so während der Fahrt ausgestiegen sind. Was nicht so ein mega Problem ist bei größeren Kindern, weil der fuhr ja jetzt nicht sonderlich schnell.
Im Zweifelsfall, ich hab mir öfters mal überlegt, die Bahn zu nehmen, um schneller von A nach B zu kommen. Ich hab mir dann überlegt, dass das Laufen die effizientere Variante ist.
Ja, es ist entspannt. Aber da kann man auf jeden Fall noch dran arbeiten. Aber trotzdem war dieser Partytrain von seiner ganzen Erscheinung her einfach ein super Ding. Man steht halt irgendwo so rum und auf einmal kommt so eine johlende Partymasse, die auf diesem Zug in Schrittgeschwindigkeit durch die Gegend geht, Cocktails von vorne nach hinten durchreicht.
Und in der Nacht dann auch noch schön beleuchtet.
Schön beleuchtet natürlich. Also das hat bei mir wieder alles richtig gepasst. Und diese Kreativität der Teilnehmer, das finde ich, das macht auch diesen Reiz aus. Und dieses Draußen sein und diese 24-Stunden-Bespielung, das macht auch alle so verrückt. Ich meine, so am ersten Tag sind immer alle noch voll gestresst und ankommen und gucken. Und was gibt es denn eigentlich so? Und dann nach dem ersten Mal Schlafen hat man das dann so halbwegs gescannt und man weiß, wo was ist. Und dann bricht irgendwie der Wahnsinn aus. Das ist ja auch auf dem Kongress eigentlich ähnlich. Dann kommen dann alle auf so verrückte Ideen. Und ich glaube, nach zwei Tagen hatte dann diese Zugbespielung dann auch schon, muss ich nochmal kurz ausholen, also die C-Base hat ja auch so eine eigene Blinken-Lights-artige Installation, diese Martelights, diese aus Lampen, Innenmarte, Flaschen, Innenmarte, Kisten, die dann so quasi durch den Boden durchscheinen. Das stand ohnehin schon in der Nähe der Tracks. Und dann, weiß ich nicht, haben die da so einen GPS-Trecker noch auf dem Zug draufgehangen. Auf jeden Fall waren sie in der Lage, auf diesem Pixel-Display den Rundkurs anzuzeigen. Und es blinkte immer an der Stelle, wo sich gerade der Zug befand. Also das ist einfach wieder so eine göttliche Nerd-Installation vom Feinsten.
Jeden Abend gab es was Neues zu sehen in den Villages. Jedes Village hat sich eigentlich verändert. Ja, zum Beispiel eben das Martelight, das dann den Rundkurs angezeigt hat.
Das ihr übrigens normalerweise in der Sea-Base bestaunen könnt.
Genau, die Sea-Base hat diesmal wirklich ziemlich gebrockt.
Also es gab einen 1 zu 1-Clone, das habe ich ja auch im Teaser geschrieben, wie es denn kam, dass auf einmal der Fernsehturm mitten in der brandenburgischen Einöde stand. Und sie haben es echt gut versteckt. Sie haben die ganzen Einzelteile nämlich so hangar gleich in einem Zelt erst vorgehalten und dann stand auf einmal eine Kopie des Fernsehturms inklusive rotierendem...
Das wusste keiner?
Das wusste nur ganz wenige. Und sie hatten halt dieses Workshop-Zelt, glaube ich, was noch nicht in Betrieb war, irgendeins dieser Zelte, die nicht an Tag 1 in Betrieb waren. Genau. Und ich bin da nur, weil ich da quasi Infrastruktur raus tragen musste, reingegangen und wurde auch auferlegt und so, dass dann wirklich als große Überraschung dieser Fernsehtürme als 1 zu 1 Kopie natürlich doch deutlich kleiner mit rotierender Kuppel an den Start gehen konnte.
Also dicke Props an die Base, das war wirklich ganz großes Kino. Aber auch diese hell 9000 Installationen, wer hat das nochmal gebracht? ICMP oder wo war das? Erlang? Was? Ja genau, war bei euch. Also bei Erlang. Ich will ja nichts falsches sagen jetzt. Aber irgendwo so in dieser Straße war das. Auch ganz toll. Also diese ganzen Kleinigkeiten, einfach schöne Sachen und das erfreut mich auch besonders zu sehen, dass das einfach in zunehmendem Maße auch so gesehen wird, dass das Camp auch so ein Outlet ist für so schönen Wahnsinn. Dass man über das Camp so nachdenkt, dass man sagt, da muss man was Besonderes hinstellen. Es gab auch, ich fühl mich nur halb qualifiziert, diese Aussage auch nur zu wiederholen, aber so aus amerikanischen Kreisen kam auch schon so, ja das ist irgendwie so Burning Man ohne Wüste, wo man so Sachen hinbringt, wurde jetzt zwar am Schluss nicht alles verbrannt, aber so dieser Gedanke einfach für begrenzte Zeit, für so einige wenige Tage einfach so den schönstmöglichen Kunst-Base zu bauen und dann eben mit diesem spezifischen Nerd-Ansatz mit Technologie und das dann eben auch noch mal besonders sophisticated zu machen, das dann so zu bauen und danach ist es halt weg und wer nicht da war, hat es halt nicht gesehen und wird so nie nachvollziehen können, das ist schon so einer der Reize, der von dieser Veranstaltung ausgeht.
Das sind immer das, wo man seinen Kollegen sagt, ihr müsst dahin kommen, ihr müsst dahin kommen, ja, ja, ja, dann verpeilen sie.
Camping und so, ich hasse Camping.
Und wenn sie dann hinterher in der Zeitung lesen oder von Freunden hören, was da alles im Einzelnen abging, dann ärgern sie sich Grün und Blau. Ja, das ist ja schon. Habt ihr sonst noch irgendwelche besonderen Fnords, die euch besonders aufgefallen sind?
Oder hast du deine Liste schon durch?
Nein, ich hab meine Liste noch nicht durch, aber ich wollte noch gekonnt die zwei Minuten bis halb überbrücken.
Noch ein Anekdötchen.
Ach ja, genau. An dem Seen, dem besagten See, in dem ich persönlich sehr oft war, also sprich eigentlich bei jedem Weg zurück zum Backstage, immer erst mal kurz im See, weil es war einfach zu heiß. Da war dann ein Schild, da stand dann irgendwie No FKK. Das stand schon, als wir zum Aufbau angekommen sind dort. Und wir haben uns immer angeguckt, so, no FKK, naja gut, okay, Badehose, okay. Und wir haben die ganzen Tage immer gesagt, ja, macht das jetzt inner ab oder lassen wir das jetzt dran? Also es war kein richtiges Schild, es war so nur mit Pappe so drangeklebt. Und wir haben dann die ganze Zeit immer, ja eigentlich muss das weg, weil was soll das? Hier so viele Kinder sind hier dann nicht mehr nachher, wenn dann erst mal zu ist und ja. Und dann haben wir am ersten Tag, haben dann selber und ich dort gesessen, völlig erschlagen und sitzen da und gucken. Und es ist immer so, so ein Nerd geht so hin, guckt sich kurz um, reißt das Schild ab und geht weg. Ich sag, jetzt haben wir den historischen Moment mit ermäbt. Und es hing da ein neues Schild dran, da stand aber No Glass drauf, weil die Flaschen dann dort doch ein bisschen gefährlich waren. Also super Sache, wir sind da dafür oder dagegen. Oder naja, irgendwas. Gegen Flaschen. Wir sind gegen Flaschen.
Flaschen kann eh keiner brauchen. Und die andere Sache, die jetzt leider nur die Leute sehen, die dich im Stream sehen, du hast die wunderschöne Kapitänsmütze auf. Ja, hervorragend. Das war nämlich auch so dieser besondere Reiz irgendwie, dass ihr als Orga-Team so dieses BR-Alles-Alles-Fail so stilistisch rübergebracht habt. Aber organisationsmäßig war ja dann doch irgendwie alles gut.
Ja, bestens vorbereitet und so. Ganz klar, von Langehand geplant. Sepp, sag du mal was.
Wir sind natürlich nicht fertig geworden. Also wir hatten da noch ein bisschen mehr.
In Betriebnahme vor Fertigstellung heißt das. Das ist der Untertitel dieses Projekts.
Es war dann irgendwie so an Tag Null. Ja, so richtig weit seid ihr aber noch nicht. Ich sag, ey, das gehört zum Konzept. Hast du mal noch Tausende? Wir brauchen noch ein bisschen mehr Budget. Ja, aber irgendwie war es ja dann doch ganz geil.
Ja, schwierig zu toppen.
Ja, es war einfach ein super Ding. Ich kann da als Außenstehender sprechen. Ich habe zwar am Bär teilgenommen, aber die Organisation eigentlich im Vorfeld nicht wirklich begleitet, außer dass ich ein paar Anforderungen mit reingegossen habe. Es war einfach wunderbar. Erstmal finde ich es super, dieser schämische Blick auf die Berliner Realität. Leben mit Fail. Das ist ja sozusagen das, was man in dieser Stadt dann einfach auch wirklich immer irgendwie hat. Und nichts hat es halt so sehr zum Ausdruck gebracht wie dieser Flughafen. Und das dann einfach so als Titel zu nehmen, das ist einfach perfekt. Also das war einfach ganz großes Kino. Und wie das am Ende auch alles aussah, es war einfach so wunderbar gelebter Trash. Es kam halt irgendwie alles zusammen. Nichts war am Ende so, wie es geplant war. Also zumindest nicht vollständig. Da kam ja noch in den letzten zwei Tage vorher, wo ja dann nochmal irgendwie ein ganzer Lastwagen mit Deko von einer Party rangekarrt. Das stand irgendwie auch nicht auf der Planungsliste.
Dann habe ich noch eine abschließende Frage, kurz bevor wir die Musik anwerfen. Wer von euch hatten dann tatsächlich sein Badge in Betrieb genommen, noch auf dem Camp?
Ich auch nicht.
Keiner.
Da fragst du jetzt glaube ich echt die falschen.
Wir warten bis zum Datengarten.
Aber ich glaube, das haben einige getan. Also ich habe auf jeden Fall einige dabei beobachtet und mit ihnen auch gesprochen darüber, was sie da jetzt gerade versuchen. Wie viele erfolgreiche in Betriebnahmen von ersten Prototypen, von ersten Ideen es gab, vermag ich nicht zu sagen. Das ist natürlich eher was für die Spezialisten. Aber letztlich glaube ich, hat auch niemand die Erwartung gehabt, dass dieses Badge schon auf den Camp zum Einsatz kommt. Das passt dann wunderbar auf den Kongress.
Über dieses Badge unterhalten wir uns gleich nach der kleinen Musik. So, und wir sind zurück im Chaos Radio 2015, in dem wir uns, und diesmal sag ich es richtig, über das Chaos Communication Camp unterhalten.
2015.
2015, also dem Starbuck kann man es auch nicht wirklich recht machen.
Doch, einfach nur richtig machen.
Schon funktioniert es. So, und der, der da so dreckig ins Mikrofon lacht, das ist Tim und als dritte in der Runde haben wir noch die Arianna. So, und ich habe das gerade schon angekündigt. Wir sitzen hier mit drei Leuten, eigentlich mit vier Leuten in der Runde, die alle diesen Badge noch nicht in Betrieb genommen haben.
Also du auch nicht?
Nee, ich auch nicht. Weil, wann denn? Bekanntes Problem. Was wir allerdings mal machen können, ist kurz anreißen, worüber wir hier eigentlich reden, wenn wir von einem Badge reden.
Genau, und warum eigentlich auch? Also es gibt ja diese Tradition auf Hacker-Veranstaltungen, wenn ich mich nicht irre, hat das einen Ursprung, ich glaube die ersten waren so Defcon, kann das sein? Die haben irgendwie angefangen, irgendeine Elektronik auszugeben als Badge. Ich kann mich jetzt auch nicht mehr so richtig dran erinnern, was die so... Ich glaube die ersten haben einfach nur geblinkt. Geblinkt, so Elektronik. Das PCB, also die Leiterplatte war irgendwie in einer schicken Form, aber ansonsten hat die glaube ich nicht weiter was gemacht. Genau, daraus hat sich das so ein bisschen entwickelt, und auf dem Camp gab es ja, das war vor vier Jahren mit der Rocket, oder war das noch länger her? Ne, Rocket war vor vier Jahren. Ne, ich glaube das war vor vier Jahren. Vor vier Jahren auf dem Camp war das glaube ich mit der Rocket, also in Raketenform.
Also das war eine Leiterplatte.
Es gab vorher Sputnik, gab es vorher noch.
Es war eine Leiterplatte, muss man nochmal dazu sagen, die aussah wie eine Rakete.
Genau, und Starbuck hat gesagt gerade, vorher gab es Sputnik. Halt doch mal die Kamera. Sputnik, das war ja auch schon im Prinzip so die Idee, das mit dem Checking zu machen. Also man muss sagen, Sputnik war eigentlich insofern, glaube ich, ein Schritt nach vorne. Wann war denn das? Das muss 2008 oder so sein. 2007 rum gewesen sein. Und das war quasi so ein Badge für jeden. Das war so ein aktives RFID-System, womit man halt auch gleich getrackt werden konnte. Das heißt, es gab nicht nur diesen Badge, sondern es gab auch entsprechende Empfänger, die auf dem ganzen Kongress rumhingen, also auf dem BCC damals noch in Berlin. Und das hat so mehr oder weniger gut funktioniert. Und man schaut ja dann immer ein bisschen weiter nach vorne. Die Rocket war dann eben auch schon so ein richtig programmierbares System mit Display. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was die alles noch so konnte.
Hast du das noch irgendwie auf dem Zeiger?
Das ist auf jeden Fall auch Inter-Batch-Kommunikation. Hatte die Rocket schon. Also konntest du dann irgendwie auch Games drauf spielen und wie halt so gegeneinander spielen und halt so das übliche, so dass den Farbplan dir anzeigen können. Also das, was man halt irgendwie von so einem Batch erwarten würde, wenn er irgendwie cool ist. Genau und das Radio, das ist jetzt hier dieser Apparat, das kann man ja mal für die per Video teilnehmenden Menschen vor das Glas stellen, zeigen. Relativ klobig, also das ist ja nun wirklich jenseits der Kreditkarte, das ist ja schon eher so Portemonnaie-Größe. Aber steckt auch eine Menge drin, nämlich ein SDR-System Software Defined Radio. Das heißt, hier kann man in Software im Prinzip alles steuern, was über so einen Funkkanal rein und raus geht. Sprich, das Ding ist einfach offen für alle möglichen Funkfrequenzen und damit auch über alle möglichen Protokolle, die man über diese Funkfrequenzen sprechen kann. Also es kann sowohl normales UKW-Radio sein, als auch Digitalfunk in irgendeiner Form.
Nur die passende Antenne muss man gegebenenfalls montieren.
Genau, ich glaube, es geht bei ein paar Megahertz los und bis hoch zu 6-7 Gigahertz. Also so einen riesengroßen Spektrum abgedeckt, sowohl senden als auch empfangen. Und irgendwie ist ein CPLD, also ein FPGA drauf. Das heißt, du kannst auch in nahezu Real-Time die ganzen Signale verarbeiten.
Das heißt, ich brauche nicht unbedingt irgendwie einen Rechner, um das zu verarbeiten. Der Rechner ist halt drauf. Der, der ein FPGA drauf ist, war mir tatsächlich neu.
Genau, also es ist ausreichend performant, um die Dinge ganz unabhängig von einem Computer zu machen. Und das ist, sagen wir mal, auch das Besondere daran. Abgesehen davon, dass es so in der Form, wenn man das jetzt so kaufen würde als Produkt, sicherlich deutlich teurer gewesen wäre. Also es ist natürlich auch so, dass das hier einige Sachen oder Chips gesponsert sind. Also ich glaube NXP war da jemand, der mehrere 10.000 Euro an Chipkosten gesponsert hat, was natürlich die Kosten auch reduziert hat. Nichtsdestotrotz war es immer noch sehr teuer und ein großer Teil des Eintrittspreises irgendwie geht an gegen das. Genau, aber das war halt einfach mal die Idee. Man gibt halt einfach jedem, der kommt zu einem Teil, egal ob sie jetzt unmittelbar was damit anfangen können oder nicht. Weil damit hast du natürlich eine Installed Base. Und ich denke mal, Leute, die jetzt nicht zu romantisch drauf sind und wirklich sehen, dass sie damit nichts anfangen können, werden die sicherlich auch an befreundete Nerds dann weiter erreichen, die eben wirklich auch was damit machen. Das werde ich mit meinem Gerät wahrscheinlich auch so halten. Auch wenn ich mir da jetzt noch keinen ausgesucht habe. Also einfach einen niederschwelligen Einstieg in Software Defined Values, einfach zu programmieren. Es gibt halt genug Leute, die was dafür programmieren. Es gibt irgendwie einen Git Propositor, wo irgendwie halt Leute ihren Code auschecken können, andere Leute es wieder einchecken und damit rumspielen. Das heißt, prinzipiell ist das irgendwie, also trotzdem so hohe Kosten verursacht hat, eine ziemlich gute Idee, um halt irgendwie eine große Basis an Menschen diesen Programmieren von Sachen und in dem speziellen Fall Software Defined Radio nahezubringen.
Und an der Stelle noch ein Programmhinweis zum Radio. Hat der CCC München drei Podcastsendungen produziert, die ihr auf der Seite des CCC München anhören könnt, zum Thema Radio. Da kommt das halt auch her. Genau, das wollte ich gerade drauf kommen, denn das Ganze ist eine Initiative, die glaube ich von München an stand insofern solltet ihr da, wenn ihr euch für das Thema interessiert, auf jeden Fall mal reinhören und wenn ihr noch so ein Radio braucht, dann schreibt doch mal Tim, der hat seins abzugeben.
Na ja, so schnell wird das nicht gehen.
Schade.
Es gibt ja auch den Datengarten.
Weißt du, was du anrichtest mit solchen Hinweisen?
Ja, ich weiß, aber...
Zehntausend Mails. Nein, nein, ich weiß schon, wie ich das gebe.
Schade. Also an dieser Stelle, bitte schreibt Tim keine Mails. Es war nicht... Es war nicht...
Genau, schreibt Briefe.
Ja. Damit hätten wir jetzt auch diesen Badge, der übrigens auch ein Display hat. Also es ist tatsächlich auch als Badge verwendbar.
Ich finde der Name Badge ist einfach... Badge kann man das nicht nennen. Das heißt Radio. Wenn man genau hinschaut, das finde ich ziemlich putzig eigentlich. Da ist hier oben ja auch nochmal... Ist das eigentlich auch eine Antenne oder sieht das nur aus wie eine?
Also soweit ich weiß, ist eine Antenne tatsächlich für einen Frequenzbereich integriert.
Dann ist das wahrscheinlich die, die hier wirklich so als normale Teleskopantenne auch angedeutet ist auf dieser Platine. Komm doch mal her. Ist nicht so? Endlich wagt sich mal jemand mit Kompetenz hier.
So, hallo, erstmal hallo. Tritt doch mal jemand gerade die Kopfhörer ab.
Schön, es wird auch komplett ausgestattet. Jetzt haben wir es geschafft. Jetzt haben wir so viel dummes Zeug geredet. Ist endlich mal jemand Kopfhörer.
Hallo, ich bin Valle. Und ich habe ein bisschen auf der Web schon rumgelötet. Deswegen kann ich mal zeigen, wo da die Antenne ist. Da wo die SMA-Buchse ist, drunter, findet man so ganz klein...
Was ist die SMA-Buchse?
Eine Buchse, mit der man weitere Antennen anschließen kann.
Das goldene Ding zum Drehen.
Wer das gerade anguckt, der kann das sehen.
Direkt unter dieser SMA-Buchse, die so nicht auf allen Badges drauf ist, weil man die noch anlöten muss, befindet sich im Kupfer so eine aufgewickelte Spirale.
Und weißt du welcher Frequenzbereich das ist?
Das ist für 2, 4 Gigahertz geeignet, sagten mir die Münchner. Ich habe selber nämlich auch noch nicht in Betrieb genommen. Und tatsächlich, um so eine externe Antenne anschließen zu können, muss man dann noch so eine Brücke umlöten, damit auch irgendwie das Signal dann nicht zu der internen eingebauten Antenne geht, sondern eben auf diese Buchse.
Und es gibt noch eine ganze Reihe von Erweiterungskits. Was wir sehen, da ist schon ein Gehäuse, ich glaube ein Laser geschnitten ist. Genau, das heißt, man konnte auf dem Camp auch einige Sachen dort machen und man konnte Erweiterungskits erwerben.
Genau, also zum einen mal diese Buchse. Es könnte noch eine weitere Buchse zum Sync mit anderen Badges, sagt der RF Guy, habe ich noch nicht verlötet, noch nicht ausprobiert, verbaut werden unten rechts. Und zusätzlich, um Abstreuung zu verhindern, hier zwei Radio Cages über die empfindliche Elektronik. Und zusätzlich noch für mehr Blink ein paar LEDs.
Da gab es noch mal einen separaten Satz LEDs zum Anlöten. Die habe ich auch irgendwie bestellt. Aber vor dem Anlöten kommt glaube ich erst mal die generelle Inbetriebnahme. Wie war das? Fertigstellung vor?
Inbetriebnahme vor Fertigstellung.
Ah ja, genau. Inbetriebnahme vor Fertigstellung. Genau, und das ist wahrscheinlich bei dem...
Boot hier sogar richtig.
Es muss es aber wenigstens für die Leute, die zugucken in die Kamera, so mit mehr Blink. Also was wir hier sehen, das muss man vielleicht mal beschreiben, ist, wir sehen jede Menge LEDs und einen mini kleinen vergleichsweise LCD-Screen, die man wahrscheinlich unter diesen gepimpten LEDs gar nicht mehr richtig lesen kann.
Nee, da wurde man auf dem Camp auch manchmal so angesprochen, mach das doch mal aus, weil wenn man da so um zwei nachts mit so hellen LEDs in der Gegend rumrennt, ist es ein bisschen anstrengend.
Ja, also gerade als Batch nachts würde ich das nicht unbedingt die ganzen Leute herum aufnehmen wollen. Aber auch das ist relativ gefahrlos, weil die meisten Leute das wahrscheinlich alles erst hinterher machen.
Mit ein paar Leuten habe ich geredet und einer hat dann auch was geschrieben, was irgendwie die LEDs auf 20% Helligkeit laufen lässt.
Und was würdest du meinen, was ist jetzt so die Killer App für das Teil?
Also das erste, was ich gedacht habe, dass man vielleicht hätte gebrauchen können, wenn mein Beifahrer das so gemacht hätte, wie andere Beifahrer das gemacht haben, wäre ein FM-Transmitter fürs Radio, wie Heimfahrt. Ja, als Fahrer kann ich doch jetzt nicht. Ja, ich bin gefahren und mein Beifahrer hat sich da jetzt nicht engagiert, aber andere Beifahrer haben das.
Ihr habt dann sozusagen den Lötkolben direkt installiert im Auto?
Nee, aber wenn man das schon auf dem Camp fertiggestellt hat, dann kann man ja vielleicht auf dem Rückweg schon ein bisschen ein eigenes Radio hören.
Ist da eine Klinkenbuchse dran eigentlich?
Ja, aber frag mich nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Aber FM-Transmitter im Sinne von spielt Files ab?
Ja, man kann da relativ fertige Patches anscheinend für GNU Radio direkt anschließen und dann die Funkwellen mit dem Computer bespielen.
Ist das wirklich die Killer App für die Heimfahrt?
Das ist die Killer App für die Heimfahrt und mehr habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen.
Hast du was im Sinn oder hast du was gehört, was Leute so meinten, dass es so sein müsste?
2, 4 Gigahertz ist ja sicherlich erstmal ein interessantes Spektrum. Dann ist da noch was drauf, glaube ich, um die Kommunikation von Flugzeugen mitzuhören. Also einfach nur so Positionierungen.
Es gibt ja diverse Sachen, die auf Funk funktionieren, sei es Alarmanlagen oder Kommunikations-Zwischenzügen oder was auch immer. Das kann man tatsächlich alles damit machen. Das ist halt wirklich universal, zum Mobil vor allem auch. Das heißt, immer wenn du draußen unterwegs bist und denkst, da ist so eine Antenne und ich würde jetzt mal gerne wissen, was die tut, dann schaltest du das Gerät an und guckst mal, wie was darüber geht.
Und das Spannende ist, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, noch abschließend, das Ganze ist kompatibel zum HackRF-Projekt, das ist auch so eine Platine. Und die Software ist, soweit ich weiß, kompatibel. Was bedeutet, man kann da schon auf relativ viel Community-Arbeit zurückgreifen. Genau, und dann dieser Badge nochmal als ganz spannende Sache, was wir glaube ich noch vergessen haben. And now for something completely different. Engel, freiwillige Arbeit. Wir haben immer gesagt, wer da im Vorfeld an der Orga aktiv ist. Aber letztendlich sind das ja die Leute, die zwar die Verantwortung haben, aber die ganzen kleinen Arbeiten, die ganzen kleinen Details machen ja letztendlich nochmal ganz andere Leute. Erzähl doch mal, wer ist so ein Engel, wer macht das und warum sollte man das machen?
Also ich glaube, Engel gibt es schon seit es den Kongress gibt, oder zumindest nach den ersten paar Kongress gab es Engel. Das sind halt die Leute, die helfen, den Kongress oder das Camp überhaupt erst durchzuführen. Also seit es angefangen von die Klosse sauber machen oder an den Vortragsseelen Eingangskontrolle, also dass die Sitze irgendwie ordentlich belegt sind. Oder die Heralde, die die Vorträge ankündigen, die die Speaker einweisen.
Gucken, dass die Wege frei bleiben.
Also wirklich alle Aufgaben im Kongress werden von Engeln gemacht. Und ich glaube auch jeder, zumindest jeden, den ich kenne, der schon eine Weile dabei ist, hat irgendwann mal früher als Engel angefangen. Bei mir war es der 13C3, glaube ich. Und dann saß ich auch in die Nachtschicht an der Kasse und habe halt komische Videos geguckt, während ich noch nichts zu tun hatte. Das gehört halt einfach dazu. Wenn man in diesem Club irgendwann mal reinrutscht zum Kongress, dann macht man einfach Engel.
Man kommt da auch rein zu kommen, nehme ich.
Du hast halt irgendwie eine gute, wenn du halt keine Leute kennst, dann ist das erstmal natürlich eine gute Gelegenheit, Leute kennenzulernen, die halt alle auch ähnliche Interessen haben. Das heißt, dann hast du halt irgendwie was zu tun auch, hast Leute, mit denen du was tun kannst, unterstützt das Event selber und ist halt einfach so, wie es halt laufen sollte. Und vor allem, man lernt halt auch einfach den Event als solchen kennen. Man lernt die Organisation dieser Veranstaltung kennen. Das Beste, was man eigentlich machen kann, ist, es gibt so Spezialisten, die graben sich mal irgendwo so ein in so einem Bereich und dann bleiben sie auch irgendwie dabei, weil das ihr Ding ist. Genauso gibt es aber so Hopper, die eigentlich sich sagen, jeden Kongress mach ich in einem anderen Bereich, um einfach mal so in vier, fünf Jahren vielleicht nicht alles, aber zumindest sehr viel Unterschiedliches gesehen zu haben.
Also quasi mal so ein Camp oder so ein Kongress durchzuspielen.
Genau, und alles kann sehr interessant sein, auch wenn das jetzt so, was weiß ich, Eingänge bewachen und so, das klingt natürlich jetzt erstmal langweilig, ist auch vielleicht teilweise langweilig. Auf der anderen Seite hat man auch so ein bisschen Leerlauf und kann die Veranstaltung auch auf einer ganz anderen Perspektive sehen. Du siehst so viele Leute an dir vorbeigehen, du kriegst einen ganz anderen Blick auf diese Veranstaltung. Wenn du in NOC oder VOC oder sowas, also in diese elementaren Infrastrukturen reingehst, dann kriegst du auf einmal das Vortragsprogramm in so einer Megadichte mit. Du siehst halt auch überhaupt mal, was während der Veranstaltung netzwerkmäßig da so geht, was da so für Probleme entstehen, was da für wilde Aktionen getrieben werden, sonstige Attacken reinkommen, abgewehrt werden müssen. Was für Probleme einfach entstehen. Und das ist auch ein super Praktikum. Also ich denke mal, man kann in so 3-4 Tagen Kongress oder Camp mehr lernen als wahrscheinlich in so einer kompletten IT-Ausbildung. Das ist vielleicht etwas überzogen, aber man lernt einfach Dinge kennen, die man vor allem so auch in der Form nirgends wo sonst antrifft. Also allein diese Netzwerkinfrastruktur, oder sagen wir mal die Technologieinfrastruktur des Kongresses und des Camps, das gibt es nicht, das kann man nicht kaufen. Das sind dann auch wirklich so ganz Vorreiterrollen. Ich weiß noch, auf dem ersten Camp, da waren wir dann halt WLAN. Das gab es halt noch nirgendwo, aber wir haben wieder angefangen, die ersten Exis-Prints aufzubauen und die ersten PCMCAE-WLAN-Karten zu verteilen und das einfach mal auszurühren, wie das funktioniert. Das war halt Jahre, bevor das auch sinnvoll irgendwo eingesetzt wurde.
Und nochmal, um auf das zurückzukommen, hast du gesagt, man sitzt irgendwie am Eingang und wartet im Prinzip, weil man eine Nachtschicht hat. Also ich hab da schon genug Anekdoten gehört, dass da Freundschaften entstanden sind.
Auf jeden Fall. Lustige Sachen passieren auch einfach. Verrücktes Zeug. Gerade nachts drehen die dann immer so richtig durch und irgendwelche verspulten Aktionen finden statt, die man sonst nie mitbekommen hätte.
Und wer irgendwie seine Profession da einbringen will, ich glaube zum Beispiel im Zert bringen sich auch ziemlich viele Leute ein, die einfach so Sunny-Rettungsgeschichten auch in ihrem echten Leben machen.
Das ist ja eh nochmal so ein spezielles Phänomen. Ich glaube, wir sind auch der einzige Computer Club auf diesem Planeten, der sein eigenes Medical Team am Start hat.
Wir reden da durchaus nicht nur von Leuten, die das hobbymäßig machen, sondern die wirklich im echten Leben Ärzte, Sanitäter sind, Rettungsfahrer.
Das ist das schöne Beispiel von dem in den Hafen gefallenen iPhone. Der ist halt in den Hafen gefallen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das T-Shirt davon erfahren hat.
Auf jeden Fall meinten sie, wir haben auch noch Rettungstaucher dabei. Dann holen wir doch mal unseren Schnorchel und unsere Taucherbrille und springen mal rein.
Sie haben tatsächlich das iPhone rausgeholt.
Sie haben es auseinandergenommen, sie haben es gesäubert und es funktionierte danach noch. Das musst du erstmal bringen. Ah ja, Rettungstaucher haben. Ich meine, die haben nicht so viel zu tun. Das ist lustig, als dieser Regeneinsatz so direkt vor unserem Zelt so ein Wagen DLRG im Wasserrettung vorholt.
Ich dachte mir, so schlimm ist das schon?
Ich habe auch eine unglaublich große Anzahl von Leuten, die halt, also gerade bei diesem Camp war es nochmal viel mehr als sonst. Also sonst haben wir immer so 10%, 15% von Teilnehmern, die sich tatsächlich aktiv als Engel einbringen. Und diesmal waren es, glaube ich, 25-25% oder so, die wirklich gesagt haben, wir sind hier und wir sind gerne bereit in ein paar Stunden. Es war richtig, richtig viel. Sie kriegen dafür halt irgendwie, also sie kriegen halt was zu essen, aber irgendwie das... Und ein T-Shirt. Aber was die Leute teilweise aufopfern, also halt wirklich Stunden, Tage lang irgendwie Aufgaben machen, die man normalerweise nicht machen wollen würde. Und einfach dazu beitragen, dass sich das Camp funktioniert. Man kann das gar nicht hoch genug loben, diese Einsatzbereitschaft, weil ohne die Leute würde das halt einfach überhaupt gar nicht funktionieren. Es ist illusorisch zu denken, man könnte ein Camp ohne Engel machen. Das geht einfach nicht. Oder ein Kongress.
Also mit diesem Lobhymne an die Engel, wo wir euch auch bitten möchten. Also hallo hier.
Send me an Engel, ihr wart ganz toll.
Bitte einmal Applaus für die Engel.
Und nach allen anderen, die ihre Gesundheit ruiniert haben auf dieser Veranstaltung.
Gab es eigentlich nennenswert Kongress solche?
Ich kenn einige, die irgendwie krank geworden sind, aber auf jeden Fall nicht in der Größenordnung.
Wir hatten schon einiges. Wir hatten abgerissene Zähnegel, Muskelzerrungen, böses Saar.
Das Schöne, was wir von Zert hatten, die haben jeden Tag eine Statistik herausgebracht, welche Verletzungen, wie die...
Linker Fuß, rechter Fuß.
Genau, dann war es an einem Tag der linke Fuß, die Zeltherringe und am nächsten Mal Sonnenbrände und Schnittverletzungen. Die nehmen das alles zwar ernst, aber auch mit einem gewissen Spaßfaktor dabei.
und von euch möchte ich abschließend wissen, wie schwer war es für euch in der Realität wieder anzukommen? Also ich kann das nur für mich sagen, für mich war das tatsächlich nach dem Camp deutlich schwieriger nochmal als nach jeglichem Kongress irgendwie wieder in dieses normale Leben zurückzukommen.
Also ich hab's richtig gemacht, diesmal ich bin erstens bis Donnerstag geblieben, also noch eins, zwei, drei Tage nach dem offiziellen Ende und bin dann nochmal ein Wochenende an See gefahren. Dann ging's so. Ja, also bei mir war es diesmal auch erstaunlich, also sonst hab ich irgendwie nach so Kongressen und Camps auch immer so diese, ich nenne es immer so schön, die Post-Event-Depression, wo dann einfach, also ich meine du bist halt einfach über fünf, sechs, sieben Tage mit irgendwie tausenden von Leuten auf dem Acker, irgendwie hast du die ganze Zeit irgendwie Action und dann bist du plötzlich alleine zu Hause und diesmal irgendwie auch so bis Donnerstag irgendwie noch da geblieben und dann hatte ich mich noch besucht. Das heißt, diesmal erstaunlich gut vonstatten gegangen.
Und da gerne bei dir?
Ich hatte noch ein ganz, ganz schräges Anschluss-Event. Ich war mit meiner Mutti noch auf einem Konzert von einem italienischen Schlagersänger.
Ich glaube, das gibt dann die nötigen Übergänge.
Ganz genau. Danach hatten wir dann noch einen Tag im Spa und Montag war dann wieder Eingewinnungsphase, schön im Büro.
Man kann es entweder ganz langsam ausklingen lassen oder den richtigen Hammer.
Auch Spender noch richtig hart. Wir sollten noch eine E-Mail-Adresse durchsagen. Eine wichtige E-Mail-Adresse.
Dann sag sie durch.
Die wichtigste E-Mail-Adresse aller Zeiten.
Na ja, für die, die was verloren vergessen haben und die Hoffnung, dass es irgendwo auftaucht, besteht weiterhin. Ich hoffe, ich sag das jetzt richtig. Der Kollege, der das gerne wollte, hört mich aber nicht. Okay, ich glaube, es war Camp2015-lostandfound at cccv.de.
Klingt auf jeden Fall gut.
In jedem Fall werden wir das auch in den Shownoten nochmal verlinken, da nicken die Shownoten schon. Ja, ansonsten danke ich euch. Schön, dass ihr da wart. Und das war's schon wieder. Chaosradio 215.
Beiden. Während des Camps oder zur Vorbereitung hat man immer so, ist so viel Stress und sobald es vorbei ist, dann ist es eigentlich vorbei. Eigentlich will man es jetzt sofort wieder machen, nächstes Jahr sofort oder in zwei Monaten wieder.
Aber erst mal kommt der Kongress?
Ja, nach dem Kongress denkt man auch erst mal nicht wirklich über das nächste Camp.
Nach dem Kongress ist vor dem Kongress.
So, mit diesen Worten lassen wir euch mal wirklich alleine. Macht's gut und auf Wiedersehen.